[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Olivia Rodrigo shocking Selena Gomez
with this malfunction
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh yes cell was just as
surprised as the rest of the audience
when things started going haywire in the
middle of Olivia's 2023 MTV VMA
performance of vampire
[Music]
[Applause]
floating lights a falling camera
[Music]
even the trees were acting out
[Applause]
[Music]
but it quickly became clear the
technical difficulties were all a part
of the plan
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
with a whole Squad of dancers and
finished strong with a rendition of get
him back
[Music]
I'm just so happy that I get to do this
for a living
[Music]